[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt tue ich fahre gern schnell auto
mir sind die gegenargumente natürlich
bewusst heute will ich mir von kontrakt
tempolimite anhören
los geht's
und zwar in der tuning werkstatt von
sydney hoffmann
der 39 jährige steht wie kaum ein
anderer fürs gas geben
in seiner dortmunder werkstatt muss der
autos zu rennwagen auf im fernsehen hat
ja eine tuning show zb wenn das
tempolimit klima 120 130 je nachdem auf
einer skala von eins bis zehn wie
schlimm 1000 es wäre für mich das wäre
welt insgesamt 5800 53 ps hätten die
autos die herum stehen gerade mal 15
stück eine art riesen spielzimmer für
autofans
[Musik]
kannst du denn dann aber verstehen dass
offensichtlich 50 prozent der deutschen
sagt spaß ist ja schön und gut
sicherheit geht vor
es wäre einfach für alle besser wenn wir
ein tempolimit hätten weil ich bin viel
in der welt unterwegs und drei
monatsraten woran du festgemacht wie so
wie du bist
hey was es mit der autobahn das ist die
erste frage oder wenn ich in amerika wie
viele ich hatte doch ich hatte vor zwei
monaten drei monaten amerikaner hier
sie haben gesagt okay es in den fans
jetzt auf die aus man ist ja auch ein
tempolimit würde das image der
autonation deutschland gefährden ist er
überzeugt und damit natürlich auch sein
geschäft ein argument das übrigens auch
von der automobilindustrie immer wieder
genannt wird wäre es für euch so eine
art bevormundung und gängelung sortieren
einschnitt in die persönlichkeit ich
würde sagen letzte freiheit aber das
letzte was uns deutsche autofahrer aus
waffen für die jungs ist das ganze also
vor allem ein emotionales thema für mich
wird es deshalb zeit für ein paar zahlen
und die hat dieser mann michael mertens
ist polizist und stellvertretender
vorsitzender der gewerkschaft der
polizei
und er ist sicher ein tempolimit würde
leben retten
jedes vierte todesopfer auf deutschen
autobahnen ließe sich verhindern
[Applaus]
ich bin jetzt schon ein bisschen nervös
wir beide sind nämlich zu einer kleinen
und vor allem schnellen testfahrt
verabredet der deal
ich darf mit meinem mietwagen richtig
gas geben und er erklärt mir was er
daran für riskant hält kriegt sie schon
große bisschen schon wirklich hilft wird
kennen ihre fahrkünste nicht gerade fast
200 drauf und sagt es mir mein argument
fürs tempo
wenn jetzt genau in diesem moment ein
unfall passiert denen sie nicht
verursacht hätten sogar bremsen können
aber den unfall erste sich aber
verhindern können
und zweitens die physikalischen gesetze
können wir nicht mehr aushebeln das ist
das entscheidende
wenn der unfall passiert dann möchte ich
dass wir bei möglichst heil herauskommen
wirklich so gern ich schnell war das
mache ich nicht
ja auch eine große katastrophe die sind
abstand nicht eingehalten
also wer da jetzt irgendwie abgrund
davor die dahinter
und dann hat er uns noch ein argument
ein tempolimit würde uns alle
entspannter macher schnellfahren löse
stress aus ich sei nicht unbedingt
repräsentativ meint michael mertens er
habe aber noch bessere argumente und
nimmt mich mit zu seinen kollegen von
der autobahnpolizei in kamen
also ich habe jetzt alles gegeben habt
ihr die gelegenheit und argumente oder
fotos um sie zu überzeugen
weil sie alle hier hoffen auf ein
tempolimit erzählen sie mehr mit solchen
bildern sind sie viel zu oft
konfrontiert sie müssen opfer versorgen
tote bergen angehörige trösten
wie man sieht ist hier ein
kleintransporter auf einen lkw
aufgefahren und ja diese schadensausmaß
hat man eigentlich immer nur bei hohen
geschwindigkeiten ich bin ja auch
selbstkritisch fragt mich ja auch mein
gott muss ich den 180 muss ich dann 200
wenn es auch weniger oder einzelner
unfälle sind die zu vermeiden sind oder
zumindest die schlimmen folgen dann
denke ich schon sollte man sehr
ernsthaft darüber nachdenken dann
tempolimit einzuführen weil jedes opfer
ist ein zuviel
und dann gibt es da ja noch ein ganz
anderes argument die umwelt fridays for
future heißt das motto unter dem seit
wochen zehntausende schüler und
studenten europaweit auf die straße
gehen auch sie kämpfen für mehr tempo
allerdings nicht beim fahren sondern
beim klimaschutz die 18 jährige theresa
ist studentin und hat die demos hier in
dortmund mit organisiert mal in folge
und das dritte mal in folge sind wir
mehr als beim letzten mal vielen vielen
dank an euch
[Musik]
es gibt die verschiedensten themen wie
sie eine plastikpistole was mit dem
tempel ist austauschbar so ein haar auf
das nicht durchgesetzt
auf jeden fall es wird in deutschland
von der politik fühlen sich therese und
die anderen ohnehin im stich gelassen
und nach dem nein der regierung in
sachen tempolimit einmal mehr könnt ihr
ihn verstehen dass leute gerne auch
schnell fahren und sagen hey das ist
aber unser recht hier in deutschland wir
haben hier ein problem das ist da ist
uns bekannt eine vorschau kann davor
dann muss sich auch jeder selbst sagen
das ist nicht okay ist im rennsport zu
machen und das ist nicht okay ist mit
höchster effizienz auf der autobahn zum
malen als es endlich werden häufig die
entscheidungen seien emotions basiert
getroffen und halt auch auf emotionen
von menschen die halt irgendwie 30 jahre
älter sind als wir und unsere zukunft
das nicht geht die generation die sich
heute die dicken autos leisten kann hat
das problem in 20 jahren noch nicht
wirklich aber wir in 50 jahren leiden
darunter dann auf jeden fall
[Musik]